hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about the wild feelings test the wild
Felix test was developed over 100 years
ago by two scientists who realized that
they could use a technique that they had
developed as a diagnostic test for
Rickettsia infections we say Rickettsia
infections we're talking about things
like typhus and Rocky Mountain spotted
fever so infections caused by
rickettsial bacteria it's a simple and
inexpensive test it is less sensitive
and some newer methods like
immunofluorescence antibody assays but
because it is so simple and inexpensive
to carry out it is still pretty widely
used so let's talk about the mechanism
how it works it turns out that there is
antigenic cross reactivity between
Rickettsia species and some Proteus
species I'll talk about what this means
so Rickettsia is one genus of bacteria
that causes diseases like the ones I
mentioned earlier typhus Rocky Mountain
spotted fever Proteus is another genus
of bacteria but it turns out there's
antigenic cross reactivity what this
means is that antibodies that were made
by an immune system to recognize and
fight Rickettsia species can also
recognize and bind to some Proteus
species and so what medical
professionals can do is they can make
delusions of patient serum so the serum
being the portion of the blood that
contains the antibodies and test those
against different Proteus strains
looking for this nonspecific
agglutination
the nonspecific here just refers to the
fact that they're looking to see if
there are antibodies that would be have
been made by an immune system to
recognize for Casilla species that can
actually recognize the Proteus species
in the test resulting in this
cross-linking that you see here so each
of these black rods represents a Proteus
bacterium and the red spikes coming off
each of the Proteus bacteria those are
to represent antigens antigens just
meaning something usually like a
carbohydrate or a protein on the surface
of a bacterium that can be recognized by
the antibodies there here in green
agglutination is when you get clumping
so when you get lots of these Proteus
bacteria that are cross-linked meaning
that you've got an antibody that is
bound to two Proteus bacteria bringing
them into close sort of close contact
with each other so you have all of this
cross-linking these different antibodies
again those are the Y shaped molecules
shown in green that causes clumping of
these Proteus bacteria and the clumping
is something that can actually be seen
with the naked eye and that's called
agglutination
so just to kind of summarize if somebody
is sick because they're infected with
Rickettsia all species and their body is
making antibodies to try to defend them
trying to fight off those infections
well those antibodies will be in the
patient serum and a doctor can take the
serum mix it with some Proteus and see
if agglutination happens if the Proteus
is agglutinated then the doctor can can
determine that the patient has
antibodies in their serum to Rickettsia
infections which would mean that they
were infected with something
titanosaur Rocky Mountain spotted fever
the bacteria that caused us so there are
two main methods that can be used for
the wild Felix test that's the slide
test and the tube test the flight test
is the simplest but it's not very
quantitative it involves putting patient
serum onto a slide and then adding drops
of a Proteus bacterial culture and then
rotating for one minute so that just
means rotating the slide like holding
the slide and kind of rotating it like
this just so that the serum and the drop
of the previous culture get well mixed
and then you look if the serum is
positive meaning that it has antibodies
that have been made against the
rickettsial infection those antibodies
will also non specifically cross-linked
the Proteus resulting in agglutination
and you'll see sort of some cloudy
clumping in the serum if the serum from
the patient does not have a gluten ation
that it's negative for these antibodies
meaning that that patient would not have
a Rickettsia infection so that's the
slide test the next is the two tests it
takes longer but it's more quantitative
this is where a doctor will make
delusions of the patient serum so here
you would have from the most
concentrated to least concentrated
meaning the most antibodies are going to
be in here the least antibodies are
going to be in here and you'll see a
spectrum because of a serial dilution to
each one of these tubes you would add a
drop of Proteus culture and incubate for
a few hours four to six hours at fifty
to sixty degrees Celsius and then check
for the agglutination the clumping the
most dilute too so that basically the
most eluc to mean the least concentrated
tube that shows the agglutination gives
the answer
so if you look and this is the most
concentrated and it's got agglutination
and this is the second most concentrated
and it's got a glutton nation but
there's no agglutination here then this
tube right here would be the most dilute
tube to show the agglutination and you
would look back at what the dilution was
and that would help you to determine the
antibody titer I do want to point out
one more thing and that is that
antibodies to different species of
Rickettsia will be cross reactive with
different species of Proteus which means
that you might have to do these tests a
few different times using different
species or strains of Proteus in order
to determine which kind of Rickettsia
infection somebody has if any so - to
screen them for the different types of
repetitive infections you might have to
go through this process a few different
times if you're interested in learning
more about how antibodies work then you
can check out my video on antibody
structure and function if you're
interested in how these antibodies can
be used to test for other kinds of
infections your the well Felix test is
looking at rickettsial infections but
I've got another video on the Sabin
Feldman diet test which looks at
antibodies and uses them to determine if
a person has a Toxoplasma infection so
you can check out that video if you're
interested in that but that's it for
today and thanks for watching biology
professor